i heard that you'd like to be spanked
and i was shocked because
i was like yeah i wonder why that is why
do you
feel good like it can't be hard enough i
think
well maybe no but didn't you once get
spanked and your mother saw the um
the marker oh yeah she was concerned she
was like was it listen sarah what's
going on
it was the first time i came home from
new york and like i lost my virginity
and like everything happened like in a
year
and then you know how women are like i
was
in new hampshire we only had one good
shower
and um so it was her shower so she was
like
pee you know women are she's peeing i'm
like getting into the shower
and i step into the shower and she sees
my ass and she's like sarah
and i look back in the mirror it is a
bruise
the exact shape of a hand
what are people doing to you oh my god i
don't know but i go uh
there was nothing i could say i go i i i
like to be spanked during sex
but you um you dated some guy who was
only into feet
and um he he called your feet slabs
i heard that is that true slammed
like there's a lingo with that there's
skye yeah
um do you have nice feet
he i don't know they're just feet
i mean no i don't think so i don't think
they're bad but they're
i don't know yeah but uh he's yeah
like my boobs and my ass did nothing for
him
jesus i was lying on my stomach
i had to like touch his nipples
he liked like nipple stimulation and and
then he's like
let's see those slabs and then i have to
kick up my feet he's here
my feet my feet kick up my feet oh my
goodness that's a real thing for men it
is
i know guys who are into that they like
to smell feet they like the feet to be
stinky
and let's see those slabs is the least
sexy thing you want to hear in bed
well i thought it was really funny
really how long are you with this guy
a short a short very short stint yeah
it's too weird it's too weird you know
i i know they're things i know